welcome to this video playing Grand
Master fav wheat from Reed no name in
them okay let's see now i played this
guy before with the h4 line drive back
it is taken let's see back then he
played c5 it had an almost losing
position right out of the opening let's
see a fee but if it just repeats it i
mean this sounds pretty rocky check he
is repeating it i cannot believe it
plant this crap position again amazing
okay yeah white was was basically
winning in this game I'm trying to
remember what exactly the point was I
think a 33 was best right III you know
there were many good ones I think he's
freelance best route t8 really what can
just take that
so if i go quincy three that's Mary
Queen before hmm
you should d three maybe long castle am
really kenapa soul
and yeah can you really play that but it
seems to be I don't see how to punish it
after before is playing before and
krissy three can before remarkable yeah
maybe here I don't know hmm tricky I
know that it is good for what because I
had analyzed this briefly afterwards
after the first game i played against
them some days ago and it's it's
remarkable that repeats this and it's
obviously bad for black but how do you
refute it when jim i don't know i think
it was III i mean what i played was also
good for white but just hard to hard to
determine the maximum yeah I must kill
him and then cream before it's the only
only way to to justify all this I came
so night takes a look takes down the
thing is I certainly not leading to an
edge for for the white may be here give
this check first check
yeah it's not the reputation at all
taking here just a cat equal material
end game type of position yeah and it so
it's a guess about equal cannot go to
see six because of night e six and maybe
you can play something like kinky no can
you have six no don't don't think so
give this check why for both good he
needs to go to g8 I guess then rooks is
700 to f7 maybe ok
check ya da poem okay
check time warning
yeah that's frustrating I mean he just
repeats the line that is absolutely
unplayable and I don't review that this
is frustrating ok Emmys oops one
unfortunately yeah okay my reasonably
does it a third time he'd get punished
for that now I'm look at this in more
detail I simply forgot Bishop a2s and
unbelievably unbelievabl cheeky but yeah
it was he three but Bishop a to I just
said when I look at castles and I think
in the in the first game that had that
we played a plate Queen c3 which was not
bad as well i came i went here quincy
three castles 95 but ok it's not not
like winning i had had some my
recollection was that it was more
favorable for white anyway what what
about this shower the computer wants to
take and play rock season with a
substantial advantage yeah I can't
believe that it's looking dangerous it
should be five check coming
now it's a good position can you do a
group the 895 multitude of threats night
takes we should be five so i stopped the
calculation too early simply because
what else is he going to play if it
castles along here there soon as before
b5 and 95 which is very good for white
and if he cancels short it's not g5 and
h7 is going to fall it's not like
winning but it's very good i had to
really am I need to apologize I thought
that this was flat-out terrible food
like I mean it is bad for black but it's
not like losing I'm not losing you three
and yeah remarkable I think I had played
this and the in the other on the other
game I don't know yeah I mean maybe just
really if I should spend maybe I should
really look at this and have refuted
completely next time because I'm
tibitius XY can't take it so it's only
that I don't dare to do that blitz game
this is just winning for white program
there is a position that it's that is
very comparable without h4 being played
it rises from five push-up g5 and this
is this is considered to be winning for
white but it's not it's not completely
easy now you need to be precise and then
blitz chess and you never know I think
III I don't know it i will look this up
next time I get it I get this right and
when they win against the sky thanks for
watching